rapper ASAP Rocky is expected to testify
shortly at his assault trial in sweet
and rocky along with his cousin and a
friend is accused of attacking a 19 year
old man in Stockholm last month a charge
they deny President Trump and American
celebrities have called for their
release Roxana Saberi is in Stockholm
Roxana what happened there this morning
well Michelle the plaintiff told the
court here that when he was attacked
at least one of the men hit him with a
bottle legal experts say that would be
crucial to his case because if a weapon
was used the men would be sentenced to
at least one year in prison but defense
attorney showed clips from this video
pointing out that the men were not
holding any bottles or glass the video
has gone viral shows rocky throwing the
plaintiff mustafa jeff eddie to the
ground then punch and kick him but the
rapper has pleaded not guilty and his
lawyer says he was acting in
self-defense
this morning in court rocky wore a green
prison uniform and was handcuffed when
he walked in also in court we saw the
president's special envoy for hostage
affairs a State Department spokesperson
told CBS News who's here at the request
of the White House another sign that
this case had spiraled into an
international incident ASAP Rocky's mom
is also here wearing a shirt bearing her
son's name rocky is expected to testify
here this afternoon the trial could last
until next week Anthony Roxana Saberi in
Sweden thanks Roxana